turning now to afghanistan where the
taliban controlled government is asking
for international help after yesterday's
catastrophic earthquake that killed at
least a thousand people the deadliest
quake to strike that country in two
decades charlie daggett reports now on
the disaster the rescue effort and the
death toll which is unfortunately likely
to rise
an orderly line of men prepare a row of
graves for the victims of the earthquake
a stark contrast compared to one day
earlier when rescuers were forced to dig
with their bare hands in a desperate
search for survivors
a lack of roads to the remote area meant
shuttling the injured away by helicopter
at least 1500 people have been injured
many left fighting for their lives
there was a rumbling and the bed began
to shake shabir says i'm sure seven or
nine people from my family who were in
the same room as me are dead
the earthquake struck one of the poorest
regions of one of the poorest countries
on the planet
decades of conflict government
corruption and now crippling sanctions
had brought afghanistan to its knees and
left the taliban begging the
international community for help
many aid groups fled the country after
last year's taliban takeover it's in a
country that's already on the brink we
know that it's a food security situation
is where we're talking about we're close
to a famine like situation people are
really already hanging on by a threat as
the death toll climbs even for thousands
of survivors now made homeless and
facing widespread hunger the suffering
has only begun
for cbs mornings charlie dagetta london